New York I'm back packing in New York
lissa Berlin this is Naomi is my wife
Alyssa and her sister Gwen how many
assistants is this mate Nick I'm sorry
she makes my life miserable
my mom called one of her oldest friends
from colleges kid just moved here I met
the girl once and she was something like
five sure she sucks now thank you for
showing up so many other people
clamoring for my company is your wife
Clem oh she does not climb it makes been
a bad boy it took them years to find a
path back to being normal ish I think
people never make films about ordinary
people who don't really do anything
they're out there I can take yourself do
I need to I'm worried about Naomi let's
just let this whole affair be simple
affair what a choice a word my
sister-in-law she's duplicitous she's a
liar
is this gossip you know talking about
someone as soon as they leave the room
kind of makes me feel ill why his buddy
coming back he's gonna be out a little
while you sure he's not out with
what's-her-face
why would you say that would you tell me
if he thought he only was untrustworthy
Naomi's not the problem is there a
problem
I had like the most difficult part about
being as transient as I have been is how
vulnerable I am to infatuation go to a
new place then I meet somebody and I
fall in love with him and then I just
won't want to leave
I wonder if the next time we see each
other we'll have met someone who makes
us feel or desire that's a novel concept
you